hey guys
oh my God it's September 2nd it's the
one year anniversary since I had a
stroke
and I'm still here Paulie Perrette
reveals she secretly suffered a stroke
last year things are harder than having
a stroke
but I'm still here
and I'm so grateful the former NCIS star
revealed her health scare on the
anniversary September 2nd tweeting quote
one year ago I had a massive stroke
before that I lost so many beloved
family and friends and Daddy and then
cousin Wayne yet still a Survivor after
this traumatic life I've been given so
far and still so grateful still so full
of faith and still here I feel really
blessed in my life Paulie also shared
this video talking about overcoming
several other past traumas yes I'm still
here again like how many times do I
treat death like I almost died for my
hair dye allergy I have food allergies I
am a domestic violence and a rape
Survivor and um
the I was assaulted by crazy homeless
person and almost died as for surviving
the stroke the actress opened up to E.T
about when she first realized something
was wrong explaining quote I woke up and
had no feeling on the entire right side
of my body at first I thought I had just
slept funny when I kept realizing the
extent of the numbness after calling her
doctor she went to the emergency room
immediately and was admitted into the
stroke Ward as with all stroke victims
had to be therapy checked for everything
speech Mobility Etc everything I fared
quite well thanks to going to the ER
immediately so how's Paulie doing now
well she says she's spaced a few months
of lingering effects but she's totally
okay do you know I'm still here
and I'm really I'm just truly really
grateful and
um
especially for all my rescue dogs that
are right over there
and um
I'm here
I'm still here
I feel good
been through a lot in the last two years
things that are harder than having a
stroke
but I'm still here
and I'm so grateful
and thank you
those of you who are my friends
God bless you all
I'm still here
and one thing Paulie wants people to
take from her experience the importance
of educating yourself about the symptoms
Paulie says knowing signs of a stroke
can save ourselves and others that's
what I'd like my message to be
[Music]